uh good morning uh welcome to uh Public
Works I apologize for the um delay in
the start weather's a little difficult
for some of the members including myself
um I would like to U open up um House
Bill 137 FN invite the sponsor to come
forward 179 uh 1379 I
apologize um representative
Corman thank you chairman makoni uh I
hope your knuckles are not as white uh
in a few minutes as they are right now
yeah uh I am Tom Corman I'm
representative uh from Grafton 15 which
is the city of Lebanon ward 3 I was a
professor at Dartmouth for 29 and a half
years which is relevant to this bill
bill because the way this bill came
about was during our onewe filing period
back in September I was in town doing an
erand and I ran into a staff member I
knew at Dartmouth I told her hey I'm a
representative now and we're filing
bills and she said I ride a
motorcycle and grass clippings in the
road present a road hazard they make the
road slippery and people can skit out
and as soon as she said that I
remembered from my senior year at
college one of my good friends was
riding a motorcycle and he slipped out
on grass clippings and collapsed a lung
so I figured yeah let me file a bill on
that I contacted OS to ask is there uh a
statute against yard debris and Brass
clippings in the road and they said no
they referred me to an ordinance from
Nashua which is what I modeled this bill
on so this bill says that no person or
Agency State or local agency shall
direct grass clippings or or guard
debris uh yeah yard debris more than two
feet into any paved class one two three
four or five
Highway and the reason I chose two feet
I'm not really a motorcycle rider but I
am a bicyclist and I thought well
especially for a motorcycle if you're
more than two if you're if you're less
than two feet from the edge you're
probably a little too close to the edge
anyway and I think people do need to be
able to have some slack as to where
their yard debris and grass clippings
are going if you're mowing your grass
clippings are going to go various places
and it seems like know not at all into
the road is a little little harsh so I
picked two feet I don't know if that's
really the right amount but that's
that's what I picked um and that's
really what it's about it's a a public
safety meure measure designed to make
life a little better for motorcyclists
and
bicyclists you'll notice that one of the
co-sponsors is the speaker and why is
the speaker a co-sponsor when I was
looking for co-sponsors I was thinking
who do I know in the legislature who
rides a motorcycle and I know the
speaker rides a motorcycle I asked the
speaker if he was interested in
co-sponsoring and he agreed to
co-sponsor so with that
I'm happy to take questions thank you
representative yes representative Jack
uh thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you representative Corman um I assume
somewhere in RSA 265 the is the penalty
for violating this
section yes in fact I'm looking that up
right
now it's deep in
there
yes um so it's a violation if a natural
person or guilty of of a misdemeanor if
any other
person further further questions yes
please
representative yes thank you for
coming does this doesn't affect Town
Road I beg your pardon does this Bill
affect town
roads um well it affects roads that are
class 1 through five highways and most
town roads I believe are in that
category okay then a little bit of a
problem
because if the forest comes up to the
side of the
road like this year in particular they
Dro thousands of pine cones branches
little stuff like
that who's going to pick it up to get it
off the road Road who's going to be
charged with a
Mis and the the other concept is further
question second
question there's a lot of people that
get their trash picked up and they put
it in barrels and stuff and they push it
out onto the
road and uh that's more than two
feet is that going to apply as
well thank you for the question the the
uh text of the bill says that no person
shall place or direct placement so if
something is falling from a tree it
hasn't been directed by a person so I
understand that you know stuff Falls
from trees but this is really about you
or your neighbor putting things into the
road rather than than the nature putting
things into the road we we can't control
nature the second question um when when
people are are putting their their trash
or recycling out it's in a container
right and and that that would not really
be yard debris placed into the road that
would be in a container okay so that
wouldn't apply I I would not interpret
that as applying because certainly from
the point of view of the intent of this
bill that is not going to cause a a uh
traction Hazard for anybody on a two
wheel vehicle okay thank you thank you
representative please thank
you I know some municipalities and
certainly private contractors in the
process of picking up you know doing
yard
cleanup push their leaves and grass out
to the street and then pick it up with a
you know machine that sucks it up and
throws it into a
truck uh I you know I don't know if that
two feet is going to do it and I'm
wondering if you thought about
instead of measuring it two feet from
the side of the road measuring a clear
distance from the center line that would
still you provide safety I mean I think
if
it's you know 8 feet you know if that
would still allow four feet or so at
least on the side of the road for with
these normal Leaf pick up operations is
that that something that might work into
this Bill thank you for the
question I could see something like that
the reason I thought about the distance
from the side of the road rather than
from the center is a homeowner can
easily judge two feet from the side of
the road getting the right number of
feet from the center especially for a
large Road might be a little more
challenging um I also felt like uh again
it's a matter of if you're getting
closer than 2 feet you're probably a
little too close to to the edge and
that's the really the way that I thought
about
it thank you represent
Melvin uh thank you thank you for taking
my question could you tell me how uh
you're going to enforce this or how it
will be
enforced I would imagine it would be
enforced the same way
as the other statutes in chapter
265 are
enforced um
how that is done I don't know if it's
done by municipality or state but
however that's enforced this would be in
addition represent Boger I'm sorry
followup please so you believe that the
municipalities are going to go out there
and take care of this every time there's
a complaint I would imagine that that
could happen yes thank you thank you
both rent
berer I have like two questions please
go right
ahead the the first
question a class five Road usually is a
dirt
road so what is the purpose of a dirt
class five dirt road being brought into
a bill when it's not open usually for
public traffic and you normally
transverse a class five Road at your own
risk that's question one I'll let you go
ahead and answer that one oh thank you
uh well the bill
specifies paved roads so if there were a
paved class five road then the bill
would apply I specifically did not
intended to apply to unpaved roads of
any class again uh thinking that the
traction on an unpaved road is going to
be uncertain anyway and somebody who's
on a motorcycle or a bicycle on that
road should be cognizant of that my
concern is more of I'm on a paved Road
I'm expecting traction suddenly I hit
this debris or grass clippings and I
don't have
traction second question thank you um
would you believe this is going to a uh
open up neighborhood disputes now
between neighbors because one neighbor
doesn't like another neighbor now
they're going to pick on glass clippings
because it doesn't quantify how much GL
grass clippings could be in the road it
just says grass clippings so that could
be just a little handful anywhere to a
tremulous amount of a drunk truck load
so it's it doesn't quantify how much
that is and would this also turn into
unfunded mandate on local cities to
start
policing people and how they cut their
grass thank you I really can't say uh
the way I think of it is
that if somebody is being really agreed
I about it I could imagine a neighbor
complaining um if somebody puts you know
three Blades of grass two feet and one
inch into a road and their neighbor
complains I'm guessing that there were
issues already that were going on and
this is not going to be something
new thank you um seeing no please
representative thank you Mr chairman I
do have an issue with the amount that
has to be in this for it to be
enforced is there anywhere in 26512
where it says when a traction Hazard
exists then a penalty or fee can be
charged because I can think of a lot of
situations where somebody goes to work
for the day and they put stuff by the
road to be picked up and the wind comes
up and it blows it across the road now
they get a summon they get a ticket for
something they really didn't have a
great responsibility to do anything
about it was the weather that did that
so is there
anywhere either we could put in this or
in
26512 where traction traction Hazard
comes up that they can use that and
hopefully use Good's judgment whether or
not they file a summons or give somebody
a
citation thank you
it certainly is possible that somebody
has put grass clippings a foot into the
road the wind comes up and blows it a
little farther uh of course at that
point it wasn't the person who caused it
to be placed but you raised a good point
how do you prove
that and and I don't really know the
answer to that
um if the commit the bill belongs to the
committee now and if the committee
wishes to amend the bill to specify a
law subraction or the the potential for
a loss of traction I think that makes
sense um my concern here really is is
the public safety aspect of it that that
we don't want people on especially two-
wheel vehicles to lose traction and skit
out and be
hurt thank you representative um any
further questions seeing no further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you and I will move to uh
Department of
Transportation Michael service do I have
welcome
sir good morning chairman Maki uh and
committee members for the record my name
is Michael citus I am the director of
operations at the Department of
Transportation thank you for hearing my
testimony regarding house build um 1379
relative to yard uh yard debris and
roadside vegetation
the department does not support or
oppose the bill however we do have a lot
of concerns it's understood that the
intent of the bill is to improve safety
in the traveling public the deity is
concerned about the current language and
its un unintended consequences it may
create the do staff believe the problem
the bill seeks to remedy is already
covered in RSA
23639 civil liabilities which addresses
the placement of any type of material on
the Highway which renders the highway
unsuitable for public travel the
Department of Transportation does not
support allowing any amount of debris or
yard waste being placed in the state
right away but particularly encroaching
into the paved section of a roadway many
state highways have a pave width of only
24 to 26 feet allowing debris to
encroach two feet into the pavement can
significantly impact mobility and safety
in that area we are concerned that the
way the bill is written it may may cause
confusion encourage some people to place
material in the right away and onto the
pavement for pickup disposal by others
while there are many times the
Department of Transportation may pull
brush close to the roadway it is with
the intent of chipping loading and trans
uh transporting from the area in a very
short time frame this would be for
material generated from within the
RightWay itself the department is
currently strained to remove and dispose
of this material it generates for RO
outside maintenance it does not have the
capacity to take on generated waste from
others debris piles along the roadway
can also block and divert uh drainage
which can have disastrous results that
we have recently seen when drainage
systems are overwhelmed and they run off
diverts to paths they are not designed
to flow this can damage roadways as well
as the surrounding area in conclusion
while the department understands the
intent and we are certain uh we are
concerned about the Bill's language and
the unintended consequences that may
bring to the highway system thank you
for listening to my testimony and I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you sir any questions from the
committee yes
please thank you Mr chamman and thank
you for taking my question i' I've got
an example I've got a 8in culet at the
end of my driveway that's City owned and
we all know we had this big rainstorm
and everything backed up well the covet
was full of leaves
the leaves came down from the neighbors
and ended up there so I went out there
put my boots on and I went out there and
took a rake and I rake the leaves to the
side of the road cuz the road is right
there the the road is right where the
cul is could I under this law could I be
charged for trying to clear a celv out
that the city owns So my side of the
road wouldn't get flooded out with those
leaves if they ended up in the road as a
result uh I guess I can't weigh too much
of that but the way it's
listed um if you had the new the new law
you would be able to put it out within
two feet but again if they're not picked
up anytime soon they're going to go back
into the ditch and that's one of our our
concerns is you know keeping those
ditches in that drainage way cleared and
by having more debris brought forward
into the RightWay and again even if it's
brought out to the into the uh edge of
pavement or onto the pavement that's
going to tend to block more drainage
paths thank you U thank you for the
question and um thank you sir for your
testimony um any further
questions um anyone that spoke before
wish to speak a second
time seeing none I will call the uh
public hearing of 1379 to a close and uh
we will we will recess for 5 minutes to
begin on time uh represent Corman I
never expected so much conversation
about debris and I thank
you
for um for the committee um I have to
apologize I have several hearings today
that I'm going to leave and attend to
and I'll be bouncing back and fourth in
my absent need to say represent cludo
will become chairman represent Mills
will uh be Vice chairman and uh
representative Jack who we are always
pleased will step into uh Clerk's
position for those times so I will open
up the hearing and depending on how long
it it runs uh I may get up and move my
way through
so thank
you
thank you uh the time being nearly 10:30
I would like to take the opportunity to
open up uh House Bill
1253 an act renaming the Blair State
Forest in campon is the Jane Kellogg
State Forest and with that I would like
to represent or excuse me uh bring
forward representative Gro is it groa
thank
you welcome welcome representative to
public
works thank you Mr chair good morning my
name is Jackie groa and I represent
Rockingham 24 the towns of Ry and
Greenland I'm here as a co-spon as a
co-sponsor for the bill and I do expect
the prime Spencer representative ho to
be here soon he's coming down from his
committee hearings um I'm here in
support of the bill because one of the
reasons that this Force should be named
after Miss Kellogg is her involvement in
the state moose
plate um she was a uh Prime person
involved in that program where um money
was collected for elip I did speak with
Senator Martha Clark who is the who was
the sponsor of the bill at the time and
she did confirm with me Miss Kellog's
involvement and we'll be happy to
provide remarks to the
committee so I'm here to um urge you to
support the bill um Miss Kellogg has
been a um conservationist her whole life
in New Hampshire and has contributed on
a state level which is why I think the
force is this BL Forest which is cont
which is slowly held in the town of
Campton should be named after her and
representative Hoy is here so if I could
please um present him to you I would
appreciate
it thank you representative uh
questions uh we will um representative
Hoy are you the gentleman filling out
the
card yep when you when you have a chance
um we will take you next thank you so
much thank you representative yes and if
I um if you need any further questions I
need to run back upstairs to Edna but if
you have any questions please don't
hesitate to ask me thank you or
representative f we will do that thank
you R did you uh thank you Mr chairman
uh this committee has a practice of not
raming something that's already named
for someone so but uh reading the
material it looks as though it's not
actually named for something it's kind
of happened stance that it was on the
Blair's land so if someone at some point
one of the speakers could
address uh that concern ripping the name
away that that would be great thank you
for
repres white would you rather we move to
someone else or are you all set I'm good
I'm just I've got some paperwork that it
that will address the last question
thank
you
yeah
well I guess you
do those are new cards that's
it representative ho welcome to public
works please please um hear your
testimony yes I am representative Tom
hoit um regarding the Blair State Forest
I think you as I said well this has
already been passed around apparently
it's a small
Forest um it's very well maintained in
fact when I was at school at Plymouth
State College many years
ago my conservation teacher Dr Fry
brought us specifically to the Blair
state Forest to show what a very
well-maintained Forest is like so I'm
very familiar with the
forest there aren't really aren't any
Trails there's a few hundred feet on the
Blair
Road uh no River
Frontage no parking I think you could
pull off on the side of the
road um and there's a small wooden
sign
um so that's
the description of the State Forest
there really isn't much to that's easy
to do this one I
guess uh
historically the there there are a
number of things named after the Blair
family um Blair Road and the Blair
cupboard Bridge Blair Cemetery which is
operated by the town of Campton the
Blair housee Hotel burned in
1908 uh it was it was located near the
intersection of Route three and Blair
Road the Blair Homestead is supposed to
be
located near Blair Road where I 93 now
exists uh the Blair family was one of
the first settlers in in the in the area
there's no historic s uh significance to
the name of the Blair state board it was
assigned to the land land that was
deeded to the state in 1924 by E Anthony
Chase and it was called the Blair parcel
at that
time um from a uh
regarding I'm not sure how much how much
I've
uh
gotta go over with with Jane I'll I'll
go as long as you if it's redundant just
let me
know um Jan grew up in the Philadelphia
area her family frequented Rocky World
deep Haven camps very historic family
camps operating for over a hundred years
on
Squam her family purchased a property
nearby she has maintained ties to Rocky
World deep B
cams from teenage camper to board
member Jane and her husband Ron were
Trail guides to the camps for 20 years
leading more than a 100 groups on all
day Mountain hikes in the White Mountain
National Forest as well as leaving
leading groups to half day kayak tours
on Squam Lake spending a day with Jane
left hundreds with a deeper
understanding and appreciation for our
natural resources
uh in Jane's career after graduating
from college Jane taught in northeastern
penssylvania she moved to New Hampshire
Midway through her teaching career she
taught at Holden as Central School for
12 years afterward became an Adjunct
professor at Plymouth State University
in the education department teaching
methods and supervising student teachers
in the North country of New
Hampshire um
I guess Jane's claim to fame is the is
the Moose plate in 1993 Jane and her
class of fourth grade students at
holding a central school started the
effort to make the New Hampshire
Conservation license plate a
reality New Hampshire General Court
passed legislation in 1998 creating the
M moose plate program which supplements
existing state conservation and cultural
heritage funding the Moose plate program
has contribut to the ongoing success of
hundreds of projects across New
Hampshire every county has benefited
from the funds raised through the sale
of moose
plates in
Campton uh Jane has been a founding
member or was a founding member of the
town's conservation committee commission
she has maintained remained a
well-respected active leader in the
commission since the founding in
1999 and just as a side note the reason
I'm here today is I was requested by uh
the town to speak on on Jane's behalf
and offer this
bill uh and I'm happy to do it of
course um Jane and her students
contacted the local state representative
at the times Wayne King to ask about
introducing legislation to create a
conservation license program like the
one Florida Ben benefited manate cons
conservation
the students contacted the Bureau of
Motor Vehicles in in every state to see
if they had a conservation program and
to get information about it there were
12 States at the time that did Jane led
the students to create a program along
with supporting
material projected revenues and all uh
excuse me and all the process to develop
the final legislation would take five
years Martha Fuller Clark would become
the instrumental in mentoring and
shaping the program into a conservation
and Heritage program to reflect the
strong bond of our state's conservation
and Heritage the students remained
involved throughout the
process there would always be students
who would join Jane for legislative work
sessions Jane remains proud of her
students involvement and engagement
often lobbying with the adults on
different aspects of the program for
Jane and the students it was especially
about the wildlife
conservation and we have their
perseverance to
thank
um on a personal note my uh former wife
uh Tish duny Hoy worked with Jane as a
teacher for many many
years and uh when I was asked to do this
the first person I asked was my former
wife because I thought she she would do
her the best and uh she had nothing but
glowing things to say about Jane and
whatnot although she didn't know about
the
conservation or about this
bill
um and I would say one other thing
excuse me
um Jane contacted me a few weeks
ago and she was feeling that
uh she wanted she asked me a number of
questions about how many state parks
were were named first of all were named
for
women and probably most importantly
whether they were all dead or
not um so I assured her that not all of
them were dead
so uh she was uh reassured about that
but uh it reminded me her reluctance to
a certain extent REM reminded me of
um the
movie
Gladiator when the the chief of the
military was asked by Marcus
aurelus
to um run a take over for him when he
died and run Rome until he could give it
back to the Roman
people and his response was absolutely
not and Marcus
aurelus answered saying that's exactly
why
you um you should be the person and I
think in the same sense I think
that uh I think Jane is the person that
should be should have this named after
her
um another few observations there really
aren't very many women
named uh that have Forest named after
them in New
Hampshire I think there were two donors
who donated the land and on the
assumption that they would name it
up thank you sir for your testimony are
there questions for the
representative
yes please represent thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question if if we did this would it uh
change the Blair Covered Bridge Absol
the Blair Cemetery either no the
cemeteries across the street from this
property uh the Blair coverboard bridge
is downhill from the property it has
really nothing to do other than the fact
they're name same way okay so it
wouldn't it wouldn't change change them
names no and it and it also wouldn't you
know it's not like it's ER erasing the
Blair name from New Hampshire history
but in any in any way thank thank you
thank you representative any further
questions representative yes please
represent
beger uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question the question
I have is when the land was deed in was
it
1924 was there any requirement uh as far
as what the name would be was there any
stipulation in there that it would be
called a Blair Forest well D be flipped
but I wasn't there then yeah I know but
part I I I don't know
that thank you any further questions yes
please represent thank you Mr chairman
and thanks for taking my question do you
know if this land that we're going to be
changing the name is in a conservation
easement I'm pretty sure I mean actually
right now the plan I mean the the
property actually this the state derives
income from that property's
management um as I said when I was at at
Plymouth state it was explained in
detail the proper way to manage a
forest and as far as I know that's how
it's being managed uh it does provide
income to the
state beauty to the
area um it's it's a nice little it's
it's a small Forest mind you but but
um It's a Wonderful piece of property
thank you sir any further questions yes
please fa I just U Want to note for the
record that we received a letter and a
package from the select of the town of
Campton approving this I know that's one
of the things we always look for and
appreciate you providing that than thank
you any further questions for this
representative thank you representative
for your testimony thank
you John I'm going to turn this over
all right
okay okay again thank you thank you
representative Hoy for coming and
testifying
okay okay so I will next call upon uh we
have a I'm sorry Craig I the name the
last name I having trouble reading
or Engle I'm sorry okay Craig angle from
the town of
Campton uh representing the select
board in favor of the bill welcome to
Public Works and highways
thank you very much Mr
chairman app this opportunity I will
be okay thank you very much and once
again uh thank you for this opportunity
to speak and I will be brief you have a
copy of this letter that was drafted for
the Campton select board uh we are we
are in wholehearted support uh of this
name change to recognize Jane and um we
we believe that the work that she's done
in her life has really earned her this
opportunity and we appreciate you
bringing that up for us as well um and
so I'm just going to say in closing the
select board is 100% behind this we
don't mean any disrespect to the Blair
name or anything like that and and if
you have any questions from the
perspective of the select board um I'd
be happy to answer those questions okay
thank you Mr uh Engle questions from the
committee of Mr go ahead please
representa Mills uh yes sir uh thank you
Mr angle um might sound a little weird
but is uh is Jane Kellogg still alive or
she is yes thank you very much all right
uh further questions of Mr angle for
members of the committee uh yes go ahead
please representative Newton yes thank
you for taking my question I asked a
question of if it was in a conservation
easement before and I don't think I got
a very good answer do you know if the
land you're talking about changing this
name is it a conservation easement
um we do we do not know we're here
representing this but it's not oh I'm
sorry the answer is no it is not thank
you okay okay thank you further
questions of Mr angle from okay go ahead
please representative jur thank you
thank you will will renaming change the
use at all of the of this
Forest I don't think it will there will
no additional um snowmobiling or hiking
or any change in what's happening now
and strictly what we're trying to do is
just recognize Jane give her the
recognition that we think she's earned
in her lifetime in the work that she's
done uh not only for Campton but for the
state and and for local people as well
as people outside of our area who came
to visit and and she led uh groups of
people into the environment and to
appreciate it so thank you y thank okay
representative bogar please
uh just to take off the question was
previously asked and not answered and
I'll see if you have an answer for it
were there any deed restrictions on the
naming of this Forest when it was deeded
over no so I'm being told no by one of
one of the other Representatives up here
to not not a not a selectman but one of
the other Representatives on the
committee um
so thank you okay thank you further
question questions of Mr Engle from the
committee any further questions seeing
none thank you very much for coming in
Mr angle you thank you all very much and
we appreciate your support and your time
okay all right thank you I will next
call upon Mr William copelan of the
Campton Conservation Commission in
support of the
bill good morning everyone my name is
Bill copelan and I'm on the campon
Conservation
Commission um I've been on the
commission for about two years and Jane
was really a uh reason why I joined the
uh the commission uh just her passion
for conservation and her energy on
projects um really led me to that uh
Jane and her career spanned about 25
years she's done thousands of projects
uh here and there educating the public
uh doing things but perhaps her biggest
contribution and from a Statewide
perspective has been the mov plate
program um that program is a large and
important fundraiser that provides
annual funds to protect and promote both
our environment and our cultural
heritage a very very key uh program uh
it all began when Jane was a teacher
back at the holdener central school back
in 93 her class was doing some research
on
manatees uh around Florida and they
stumbled upon a license plate program
that stated Florida had in place to help
raise money for these manatees and of
course kids being uh Curious they said
well do we have anything like that in
New Hampshire and of course uh they did
some research and no the answer came
back and then another curious student
said well why can't we do that here and
that's a great question and that all
started and planted the seeds for the
Moose plate program so in the course of
the five years uh the Jane in the class
reached out to local rep Representatives
they wrote letters they appeared at
different hearings um Jane even brought
some of her students to hearings uh here
in conquer and the whole program began
to take shape now it took five years for
this to come to fruition um and in that
time her students had become ninth
graders uh but a lot of it was the
administrative uh workings to figure
that out um and also um it's sort of
shifted Focus from just focusing on
animals the Moose uh to also cultural uh
projects which was a big need here in
New Hampshire today residents can go to
any their town hall and get a moose
plate easily for their
car now I mentioned that this was a very
important fundraiser for the state um
all of the funds raised from this
special license plate going to the New
Hampshire Department of Natural and
cultural resources
each year they review all the
applications from conservation groups
historical churches uh different
Heritage restoration uh group seeking
grant money and then they allocate that
money uh to various groups now there's
some very eye popping figures from this
moose plate program that you might not
be aware of since Inception the program
has raised more than $20
million that's really phenomenal and it
has funded over a thousand different
projects in two uh in this year alone
2024 over $670,000 are allocated for
both conservation and Heritage projects
and all these projects span across the
state in all 10 uh
counties the average Grant is around
$30,000 and that's really a substantial
amount of help to both large and small
projects
so what are some of the projects that
are going to be done this year a lot of
them may be in your own town terms of
Heritage grants there's going to be
stained glass Restoration in lonia
public library we're going to refinish
floors at chesher railroad Depot Goram
Town Hall as a balcony that has to be
done Milford Bandstand will be restored
the Franklin opera house will be
restored and in Northwood uh there are
some old documents from the 1860s that
actually will be preserved in terms of
conservation grants we'll be doing
things like Mason Brook Watershed
conservation chakur lake has some
Shoreline
stabilization uh chesher county has a no
farming uh no till farming
initiative uh there's a Chase bog
Wetland complex and a peser white
wildlife refuge and these are just a a
smattering of different projects that
will be accomplished this year
um in terms of uh if you had more
questions on the the Blair Forest name
back in the 20s that was deeded to the
state it doesn't really have any
historical um significance a lot of
things were named Blair all in the area
uh but there's there's no uh nothing to
hinder uh changing the name of that
Forest uh Jane has just done a
remarkable job both on the Moose plate
program and in all of the different
projects as an educator she has uh done
lots of things for the public we do bog
walks and uh Vernal Pond visits and
Wildlife tracking uh
excursions uh in the various properties
so she really is a is somebody you you
meet once in your lifetime that has that
passion that drive that gets things done
and we think it's really fitting that uh
the forest be renamed uh in her
honor any questions okay thank you Mr
copel yes questions from the committee
please is that written testimony sir or
is that just your notes that you were
reading um it's uh kind of my notes but
there is summarized in the packet you
have okay thank you very much you're
welcome okay thank you representative
Mills Mr copelan further questions of Mr
copelan from the committee further
questions okay go ahead representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question I'm not not sure
if you're the one to ask but uh maybe if
somebody else is going to speak we can
find out and that is did somebody along
the way uh discuss this with the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources there excuse me represent
there is a represent who's going to
testify shortly on this issue very good
thank you okay thank you further
questions of Mr Copeland from members of
the committee any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
coming in and testifying Mr Copeland
thank you yep I will now call upon Mr
James Butler of Campton and he says he's
representing the I guess the town of
Campton in support of the bill
please hello um Mr chairman committee
members I'm Jim Butler um from
Campton uh I'm also on the Conservation
Commission in Campton 2 um I've
submitted this you know the testimony
here and you know just you know the
testimony points to that you know Jane's
been involved at a state level she jumps
in things at a regional level too I
don't know if anybody knows of Livermore
Falls Regional Recreation Area it's a
state park it was not a state park
before Jane and the Plymouth rotary and
people got involved in it and um they
took a place that was 30% of the police
calls and holderness were because of
this this area being misused and now
it's a safe family oriented State Park
that U people are able to
enjoy Also Jane is the co-founder of the
Campton Conservation Commission and
that's you know for Campton that's um
been a huge um thing that's supported in
our community she's um it's resulted in
three conservation properties in Campton
and it has wide support in Campton but I
think also that you know this is a
little bit more than that too because is
um you know the US the constituents
asking for this renaming you know it's a
small forest and a small rural town and
um you know we wouldn't be asking this
because you know the forest is all
within the campon we wouldn't really be
asking this for like Livermore Falls
state forest because that is encamped in
holderness so yes you know what we are
asking for is you know more
consideration that what might be
otherwise infored because it is all with
in the town of Campton so you know by
naming the state forest which is now
doesn't you know it's just a happened to
become Blair State Forest because it was
Blair it was a Blair parcel that the
person who deed it to the
state that's what he called it but he
was not a Blair he was not part of the
Blair family it's just because some of
the frontage you know a couple hundred
feet is on Blair Road and we have a lot
of stuff that you know was Blair but
that was early you know late 1800
and it wasn't deeded to to the state
until
1924 so it is a state force it has a uh
Force management plan but it does not
have a conservation easement but the
stewards the state of New Hampshire are
very great stewards of that
land now um you know you know I
mentioned we're a small town you know
conservation is a big part of that keeps
the land conservation Wildlife
Conservation that keeps the rural
character of Campton and that is very
very important to the to the
residents almost
70% of Campton is protected land that is
either by State Forest which there's two
within Campton the wild uh the White
Mountain National Forest there's current
use as well as um conservation easement
properties we have both large and small
conservation easement properties within
Campton and at the you know at the same
time because such a large percentage of
campon is under conserv or is protected
land that doesn't mean we don't see we
have a lot we support and have a lot of
development um um and also that um this
protected land doesn't mean it's off off
limits a lot of it actually is contrary
it's required to have access for
recreation so Hunting Fishing
snowmobiling and hiking
is allowed on most of this conservation
land and it is widely used for those
purposes
too so what we're what we're trying to
do here too is take this state forest
that's all within the state of Campton
and Link it to conservation and we can't
think of a better way of doing that than
through Jane and her lifetime of
conservation so I hope that you can you
know afford US you know uh you know the
consideration as being you know this is
a state force all within Campton and
this is Campton asking for it to be
renamed um so appreciate your time okay
thank you sir uh Mr Butler any questions
on Mr Butler for members of the
committee any questions of Mr Butler
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony I will now call upon Mr
Patrick I pronouncing the name right Mr
Patrick Hackley the state Forester who's
representing the department of natural
and cultural resources division of
forest and lands in opposition to the
bill welcome to Public Works and
highways Mr Hackley thank you Mr
chairman
um again for the record my name is
Patrick Hackley I'm the state Forester
and the director for the division of
forest and lands we manage the uh the
Blair State Forest and 190,000 Acres
across the state we are part of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources um
so I appreciate the opportunity to
testify on House Bill
1253 relative to renaming Blair State
Forest in Campton as the Jane Kellogg
State
Forest the Department of Natural and
cultural resources uh and the division
of forest and lands opposes this bill
our division is the state agency charged
with the execution of all matters
pertaining to forestry Forest management
and Forest lands within the jurisdiction
of the state one of our key
responsibilities is to protect our
natural res resources for the benefit of
State citizens visitors and Forest
industry that's just to give you the
background of what we do um but
specifically to this bill um dncr has a
memorial policy and um so I'll just read
from the memorial policy permanent
commemoration on state reservations and
lands under the management of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources is a high honor affording a
degree of recognition that implies
Statewide importance and extraordinary
circumstances granting the use of a
public resource for the purposes of
recognizing a person whether deceased or
Alive group or event must be consistent
with the purposes of the property held
in the public trust and the contribution
to the Department's Mission and purpose
the policy also states that there should
be quote an an extraordinary association
between the land and the person group or
event to be
commemorated Miss Kellogg was the
teacher of the fourth grade class as
you've all heard at the holderness
school who conceived or helped to
conceive with with the involvement of
her students uh ultimately leading to
the establishment of the Moose plate
program while this is a very notable um
contribution on a Statewide level uh the
majority of Miss Kellogg's conservation
accomplishments that were shared with me
in a letter from the Conservation
Commission appear to be largely at the
local level and I don't this is no
disrespect Miss Kellogg or her
supporters in Campton clearly she's a
conservation leader
but it's our job to to
weigh renaming a state property and so
in that
context um where I'll share with you the
the final few points I
have um it should be noted that there
are several Town Forest that Miss
Kellogg was involved in helping to
conserve and those would be a suitable
um opportunity to honor her
contributions in the town Force but I do
understand the sponsors and her support
is is why they would like it to be a
state Force that's already in town I I I
get that
connection um so dncr um we're sincerely
we're also sincerely grateful for the
success of the Moose plate program um
our agency has received um considerable
funding over the years and and we're
grateful for that for that opportunity
that vehicle that
exists um but just to conclude my
remarks um renaming a state forest um
in Miss Kellogg's name is inconsistent
with our Memorial policy it triggers a
host of administrative changes in our
land management system and it does set a
precedent for other towns in the future
to uh request to rename a state forest
uh on behalf of a more local Regional
person um in in a specific case so for
these reasons we're we're opposed to
renaming of the State Forest I'd be
happy to take any questions okay thank
thank you very much Mr Hackley questions
of Mr Hackley from members of the commit
representative Abbott
please yes could I just wondered if I
understand the first and third um
objection to naming the force but I just
wonder if you could make the committee
aware of what um what it says it
triggers a host of administrative
changes in Our Land Management System
right right thank you for the question
so we've been managing this this
property for decades for a number of
years all of our maps all of our files
all of our forest management plans um
are embedded in the name of Blair State
Forest so I actually can't tell you in
detail but I have heard from my Land
Management staff that it would it would
create two identities of the same
property so I don't know if we'd have to
rename all of our files or we'd just
have to say AKA Blair State Forest but
my my forestry staff and Land Management
staff said it would be
problematic okay thank you question for
yes okay please go ahead represent FL
yes thank you do you have any examples
of forest naming or
renaming that were initiated by your
department and or or at least approved
by the department thank you for your
question
um not my short 10 excuse me my short
tenure at the agency I've been there a
little over three years but um to my
knowledge known I have a a very
experienced staff that some have some of
them have been there for 25 plus years
and they they couldn't give me any
anecdotal or any comparison of when
we've had to rename a State
Reservation okay further questions
representative Newman
please yes thank you how is the deed
showing of ownership on that good thank
you for re asking that question I wanted
to clarify that and I think our our camp
supporters know that proper pretty well
probably better than I do I've been
there once in the winter time but um so
there is no deed restriction regarding
the name of the property it it could be
changed if if this committee so approved
so that's legit that's the first thing
we checked when we got the request so
there's there's no we do have properties
that are required to stay named after
the Don after the donor okay um and
there is as was already confirmed there
is no conservation easement on the
property uh the state owns it in full
all the all the rights to that property
and we manage it in a conservation ethic
okay okay further questions please of Mr
Hackley from the committee any okay yes
please represent jur thank you chair Mr
Hackley have there been any other
requests lately of your department of
the dncr to for name changes or uh
perspective name changes that you can
think of you've been there three
years no um not that I'm aware of okay
thank you okay thank you represent jurus
further questions uh yes go ahead please
represent Newton thank you just for
clarification uh you said that uh while
notable on a state level uh in the uh
there are several sizable Town forests
that could be named in her honor are
these forests in Campton yes that are
not state forests correct they're Town
Town owned thank you yeah thank you
representative Newton further questions
of Mr Hackley from members of the
committee any further questions seeing
none thank you very much for your
testimony R I'm hack we appreciate it
thank you I'm sorry Mr Hackley okay so
there are there any other people who
wish to testify for or against House
Bill
1253 are is there anybody
else okay seeing none I will adjourn
this meeting of the commit uh of this
public hearing on House Bill
1253 um all right so now it is uh time
well okay I'm going to recess for just a
few minutes and we're going to hear our
next but I need to confer with the prime
sponsor first Mr chairman yes just a
quick question I received six
corresponden regarding the previous bill
will they be entered into the public
record the previous bill that we heard
earlier that was uh uh 1253 1253 uh we
just heard yeah okay we should yeah I
will make sure that it's put into the
public record as part of the hearing in
support the like the letters and
everything we I will make sure and I'll
work with the chair to make sure it's
put in the public record I got emails
right here absolutely emails okay Public
Works those get yes all all the emails
that come from Public Works get involved
thank you okay in addition to everything
we
get EXC okay be right
back all
right just a short maybe minute
ref
it's
an you know we
we
sad about a mile up the road just before
you get to Hayfield it's on your right
hand side big flaring
Federal Marvel and it's pretty cool so
it's it's kind of like the hress version
of the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier
it's
that I get
that well
okay I agree and I agree with agree I
just
strugg
for the you're more than welcome to stay
but I'm gonna start a hearing another
bill please okay thank you and again
thank you very much for those who came
to speak either for or against House
Bill 1253
earlier so now I'm going to open the
public hearing on House Bill um
1547 requiring mileage based exit
numbers on tier one highways and I want
to welcome the Bill's Prime sponsor
representative Timothy Horgan and first
of all I want to extend I think on
behalf of the entire committee the
committee's condolences on the passing
of your mother and I know what you're
going through I know you thank you okay
thank you and I appreciate you showing
up under such circumstances anyway so if
you could please proceed with your
testimony represent thank you so this is
um B 5047 it brings it new New Hampshire
line with virtually every other state by
numbering uh numbering interstate and
other Interstate standard highways by uh
by mileage rather than sequentially and
um that's been mandated by the federal
manual and uniform traffic control
devices since 2009 and they've been
commonplace Nationwide with since the
1980s um and the only other state which
still incluses uses them is uh is
Vermont and uh
it's probably an issue probably a lot of
people here in the legislature probably
thought about I didn't really uh know
which exit I live been living off of all
these years until I uh started getting
interested in the issue I live off of
exit 6 off the Spalding Turnpike and
that's one of the highways that would be
affected by it um actually the exit
numbers on the spaling are like kind of
weird so doing by mileage would save a
lot of confusion because for example
exit 5 recently disappeared when they
rebuilt the small thing as they said so
two of our neighboring states recently
made the change over um and I think with
no dire consequences um so the problems
that were predicted uh by some people
such as our governor didn't um didn't
happen people got used to it really
quickly so I I I happen to do a lot of
driving in Massachusetts I probably
shouldn't admit that but I friend family
and friends down there and they the
change over was painless it's actually
now easier to get around and um and in
any case the old exit numbers are still
shown on they have bright yellow
placards attached to the standard green
exit signs so like all the old numbers
are still there in case whatever reason
your GPS hasn't been updated or you're
still using a paper map or whatever so
this has been kicking around for for
several years um it was been incl
there's a project 4
4915 which has been included in the
first three initial drafts the 10-year
Highway plan and then it's always been
taken out by uh by gaset you know which
is basically as you know the executive
Council plus the commissioner of
Transportation um the first time was in
2019 and uh for reasons I don't go into
my testimony the governor made a bit of
fuss over the exit numbers um so it got
taken out um so then it was deleted by
the uh first incenter of the legislature
which became hb220 and actually became
HB 1182 because of a very unusual things
that happened in the legislature that
year so and then the same thing happened
in 2021 when they're putting together HB
2022 and in 2023 when they're putting
together HB 2024
so and I think this is a I mean I think
this is a good thing having uh drone on
having
driven on on highways on highways in
other states including um you know two
which made the change over very recently
um which make this a good time to think
about it um over in 993 we got the exit
4A and I think uh people from people
from out of state or in state are
probably may not it probably harder for
them to distinguish between Exit 4 and
exit 4 a um whereas we went through um
mileage Bas numbering we would have Exit
12 at mile poost 12 Exit 13 at Mile
poost 13 then exit 15 which is what
probably most people from out of state
are expecting to find anyway so um then
the small ing Turnpike which has always
been kind of confusing like there I
think exit 10 has never existed even on
the highway it's almost 70 years old um
and there's lots of EX there's several
exits which are on one side of the road
and not another so that's I think that
would be a highway that would be better
with uh with um mileage based exits
instead of sequential exits um and I
actually as I said I never actually real
I never really like had memorized I live
off of exit 6 until like I started
looking into this into this issue and
finally an i91 east of uh east of i93
which is the portion that's um that's uh
built it's a tier one Highway built to
Interstate standards um the mile po are
going to be changed somewhat and I guess
uh I think probably the final decision
hasn't been what to ask for but like
right now when you head east on New
Hampshire 101 which begins in in Keen so
54 hour miles east of Kean you pass
through Bedford
in The Last Mile poost I think was last
time I drove down that I was looking I
think it's number 54 and then then you
have to like you know merge into merge
into 293 and on the 93 and it's it's you
know it's not exactly the easiest
stretch of road to uh make your way down
in the state it's there's ramps coming
in from all different directions and
people trying to cut in front of you but
so it it may seem like it's 46 miles
from um from Bedford to uh I guess it's
actually it's almost Auburn but in
Manchester where you finally get on the
IE New Hampshire 101 is mile post 100
but you're actually about 60 Mi east of
keen so um there's they're going to be
redoing those mile posts anyway at some
point in the not too distant future and
but uh so may this is probably a good
time to uh change those exit numbers and
actually they're which now um starts
with exit one which is to I think Route
28 and then goes all the way to exit 13
in Hampton although oddly the two most
not that all the intersections aren't
important but the two most important
intersections to I95 and the route one
ironically are don't have numbers which
um probably doesn't make it easier for
out ofate motorists to uh find those two
exits although they're Prett although
the signage you know otherwise it
complies with the federal banal and it's
pretty clear but it just makes things a
little bit easier for our drivers and um
they didn't send it through with the
fiscal note um it would probably cost
some money but not much and so project
40915 has been in those last three draft
10year Highway plans the most recent
version was 1.3 million we would um
which I think is a I think it's money
well spent to make life easier for uh
well especially alate drivers but even
even instate drivers will probably find
it easier to it's easier to know it's
easier to check the exit number from the
mile post than try to remember what the
Last Exit you pass especially since we
have lettered exits and missing exits
and all kinds of weird things in our
Highway ways so um there's like actually
two ways to get to the goal of my bill
one is to pass this bill which was sort
of
uh which sort of ask the dot to do it in
some some future year I think we gave
him I think about 10 years to do which
is more than they need or of course you
could also try amending the 10-year
Highway plan but that's kind of a
politically sensitive subject you know
that's uh usually usually usually we
hear in the house we like to pass what
came over from gasset and sent it over
the Senate without too many changes but
that that is an option you have to do
the same thing so that's uh that's
basically my bill and I'd be happy to
take any questions okay thank you
representative Horan questions of
Representative Horgan for members of the
committee any questions of
Representative Horan from members of the
committee okay seeing none thank you
very much and you're going to submit
written testim I did I passed it around
so okay yeah if you could please do so
it'll help us there's a couple extra
copies that went around the table make
sure that yeah make sure everybody gets
one thank you all right thank you very
much for again for your testimony and
your
time okay next I will call upon uh and
I'll Beware with these names of Mr
Lee I don't know B Banus or baranis I'm
sorry if I mispronounced the last name
and Mr Bill oldenberg of New Hampshire
do representing New Hampshire do for
five minutes you indic take no position
on this bill please so welcome to Public
Works and highways and you know give us
your Insight and we would appreciate it
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Bill oldenberg I'm
the director of project development at
New Hampshire Dot and with me is Lee
bonis he's the state highway engineer at
the dot um as as representative Horan uh
stated there's a long history of this
project um in uh New Hampshire
do um it was created so a little bit of
how how Federal Highway is structured so
there's the US Department of
Transportation which oversees highways
Bridges Aviation Transit rail um and a
subsection of us do is Federal Highway
Administration that oversees highways
Bridges and basically everything the New
Hampshire dot does um they set standards
and rules um standards on Highway design
standard on bridge design and one of the
standards they set is the manual of
uniform traffic control devices it sets
standards Nationwide standards for
pavement markings signing uh
construction signing and and and the
like so one of the requirements that
they stated uh in 2009 was that all exit
numbers um in the nation should be based
upon mileage based system uh New
Hampshire uses a a sequential numbering
system as you know most to 1 2 3 3 4
five it's not mileage based
um and not only do they state that it
should be mileage based they actually
prohibit the use of sequentially
numbering system um that was in 2009 uh
some years after that we had entered a
project in the state 10-year plan uh to
renumber the signs and that has been in
the 10-year plan for the last several
Cycles um it originally um was removed
based upon um from the historical urban
legend that I hear is uh a lot of
business businesses were um upset and
and worried um that they would have to
change directions on their uh Maps
brochures Etc a lot of them use the exit
numbering for um how to get to their
their places of business um and it you
know sort of the poster child for this
is Exit 32 in Lincoln um they have
bumper stickers and t-shirts and and
magnets and everything is based upon
Exit 32 and they sort of branded that as
come to Exit 32 and you can do
everything um so they don't really want
to change and that was one of the
reasons why the bill um or the the
project in the 10-year plan was removed
originally um I think every cycle since
then for the last at least four uh
project has been entered in the 10 year
plan and it has been removed as as
representative hergan Say by through the
gaset process um that happened uh this
this this cycle as well we did have a
project in the 10year plan and it was
removed by gaset
um we have
um you know so we really don't take a
position on it we've tried to do it um
it it does offer some um and nuances and
and and changes that that are
ramifications from it uh sort of as as
representative
Oregan stated it it it
will still make some of the um some of
the directions if you come up the F ever
at Turnpike and then becomes I 293 and
then it ties into
i93 just as today those numbers go from
1 to 13 then 4 to 7 and then you pick up
11 on i93 that that won't change
there'll just be different numbers um so
uh it it does have um its uses and um
you know it it it does help um with you
know knowing the distance to exits it's
also helps an emergency response you'll
notice that along the interstate there
are what we call reference location
signs that are mileage based every 10
2/10 of a mile along the interstate
there's a sign that says what mile
marker it is um that the idea would be
is the exit sign would match that so you
knew um if you were in an accident and
you could see that you were at mile
marker
38.2 you know the the next exit of the
closest exit for emergency response
would uh would be easily denoted it
wouldn't be four it would be 38 or 39 or
something like that that to match that
reference number
um so you know we were available to to
answer any questions on the nuances of
it um we would note and I think um
representative Horan mentioned there's a
few uh logistical uh issues with the
bill um in that uh the citation in the
mutcd as noted in the bill it as luck
would have it uh Federal Highway changed
or updated or revised the mutcd last
month so the citation uh should be
updated and there's also the the funding
issue uh is the intent to add this
project into the 10-year plan back into
the 10-year plan or is it to fund it
separately because there's no funding we
did do a fiscal note that wasn't
included um and we you know we're
available to talk about that as well hey
thank you Mr Olden representative void
followed by representative Jack please
thank you Mr chairman Mr oldenberg
thankk you for your testimony I
appreciate it
um has there been any impacts either
current or future to New Hampshire's
ability to receive Federal Highway
monies that have been impacted by the
fact that we've been using sequential
mileage versus sequential exits versus
mileage B based exit um there's there's
a threat um they they can withhold money
uh to date they haven't because we've
made a goodfaith effort to include the
project and um it's been removed um uh
thank you represent I'm I'm sorry go
ahead please one follow Mr chairman
thank you sure the the follow-up
question I would ask is in in
your if if I'm putting you on the spot I
sincerely I sincerely apologize but do
you see any potential impacts to people
with personal GPS systems in their
vehicles being impacted by going from
sequential systems to mileage based
system I I don't because the the the
folks who make the garments and the um
and all those um and Google Maps uh they
they actually receive our plans um and
they know exactly what we're doing so
that they can update their uh all the
GPS for directions and and and things
like that so I don't see that as an
issue okay thank you very much thank you
representative Jack please uh thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you gentlemen for
for appearing uh there's a reference in
the bill to tier one highways is that
defined in statute anywhere my
impression was it's an internal do
categorization of Roads it is a tier one
road is an interstate basically so or or
equivalent so so one1 is yes but the
question is is tier one defined in
statute because it's referenced in the
bill I do not uh I do not believe
so okay thank you represent Jack
represent Bogart please and followed by
represent
Farner if this was not included in the
10-year plan and was done as a direct
directive to take this on what would be
the financial cost for this
project we estimate 1.4 million and
that's just about what the the the
10year plan project had in
it okay okay yes please continue
representar and if this was done outside
of the 10-year plan what would be the uh
estimated completion date or start date
of such a project um so the idea would
be is we'd have to do every each
Interstate at the same time so you
wouldn't want to have the interstate
number hodge podge so the thought would
be is we would do uh each
Interstate um as a project or or or
bundle them together so i93 would
probably be we could do all at once 89
all at once um when you get to the F
ever Turnpike and the 101 Connection in
uh probably do all that at once and then
the Sea Coast uh I95 uh Spalding
Turnpike um probably all at once as well
but we would we could e we could do them
all at the same time uh probably
wouldn't do that um just from a
Contracting standpoint it would probably
be broken into several projects but um I
don't know if time frame to do some of
them I
would sorry Lee bonus uh State traffic
engineer um as far as the duration uh so
from
from the green light to proceed um I
think a reasonable time frame would be
approximately two years for uh
engineering efforts and then a a
construction season for the
implementation uh and the reason I say
two years for engineering is uh having
to secure a consultant to um perform the
work and then
um to uh to get it done so to me it
looks like a three-year
Horizon um from the from the time that
we've secured funding and can
proceed okay thank you Mr BR you please
continue ref B uh So based on what
you're saying in the bill it says it's
given you 10 years to
completion from start to complete well
from being a uh past to completion of
2035 would that be sufficient time to
complete such a project as this oh yeah
I don't think that would be an issue
yeah I think the the 10 years allows us
some flexibility to to ensure that
priority projects don't get displaced by
um by other projects like like this one
it may fall into a u a priority within
the department and so that does give us
flexibility okay representative Farner
please thank you
just to be clear U there is no federal
funding program for these sign changings
that's separate from the general
allocation to the state so that if we
were to do this it would come out
of funds would otherwise be available
for other Highway projects is that
correct so we we uh initially as as part
of the 10-year plan project that project
was federally funded so we we were using
federal funds
um uh to to do that project if it isn't
part of the 10-year plan it would have
to be funded some other way you know
General funds or um through betterment
funds uh that we don't have but
um okay thank you uh F okay
representative Boyd
please thank you Mr chairman director
barones the do has to hire a consultant
to replace sign
on our highway system did I did I hear
that
correctly uh that that would be one
approach uh we can do it internally but
we have a backlog and and uh limited
Staffing uh so adding projects in we
like if if we have the opportunity we
like to ensure that we have a timeline
that would allow us to to utilize a
consultant the work is not necessarily
as as simple as it might might initially
appear um adding adding signs and panels
um to overhead structures can affect the
size of those structures uh which could
affect the
structural um limits of some of the uh
the sign Bridges um the the fiscal note
that I prepared made some basic
assumptions uh but didn't get into the
details of specific locations in some
cases sign panel may be too small to
accommodate a three-digit number for
instance so then we have to not just
throw it an overlay panel up but we
would have to replace the structural
portion of that sign to to ensure that
that number is there uh so there's quite
a bit of
um work that goes into ensuring once a
contractor is let loose uh on a project
that they're not going to
encoun um situ situations that aren't
going to be able they're not going to be
able to to construct so we do have to
have an engineering review of of each
and every location um some cases there's
multiple signs we have to make sure that
we've found all of the signs that make
reference to a specific exit number uh
and so that it does take effort
um the idea is that once we go to
construction that it is very
straightforward and they can accomplish
the work very quickly so that the number
changes take place over a short period
of time and the idea is to minimize
confusion for emergency responders um
where yesterday that was exit four and
now it's exit 16 uh and so uh we're
dealing with this with with the mile
marker project that uh that we we
discussed on Route 101 where there's a a
change in mile marker numbers so that
implementation has to be monitored and
and um we want to minimize the duration
of that work so
engineering up front helps minimize
surprises during the construction so if
I clarify a little bit we'll step back
and we'll get really deep into the weeds
so our our plan is like every other
state that's had to do this in the
Northeast we're not just going to change
the exit number we're going to add a
another sign panel underneath that says
either previous exit five and now we we
renumber the exit or we leave the exit
the same and some states have said mile
post exit you know 38 so I 95 up in
Maine y exactly so that and historically
their their plan is to leave them up you
know until everybody gets used to them
10 years 20 years or whenever we next
change the signs over and then take
those signs down and and leave the exit
numbers the way they are but it's not
just to change the exit number but what
that requires is addition signing adding
adding a panel or adding a square
footage of sign to every structure and
that means we have to check wind loads
and overhead sign structures and it's a
lot it's a lot more complicated than you
would think it's not just changing a
number so so just pleas to amplify
director bonus's testimony and what you
just said Mr oldenberg
when when do goes out let's just let's
just take exit three down and sale
because the governor likes Exit 3 okay
and it was alluded to by representative
Oregan in his testimony the sign that
for me to get off on exit 3 going
Southbound the stanions that go in in
that sign has been engineered to support
that particular sign so what you're
saying is is that in order to change
that existing sign from exit 3 to let's
just say exit 6 because I don't have my
garment with me it's going to say exit
six and there'll be a second sign just
to do that requires a level of
engineering to ensure that the two poles
that are out there are going to be
supportive of enough to hold not just
the original sign but the additional
sign that's going to go on to meet that
it could um I mean it it
would depends on the number it depends
on is it a full sign structure across
and are there multiple signs being added
there is a factor safety and that goes
into the design um you know initially
but we we would would require a check I
appreciate you cander thank you okay
thank you referent boy Miss yes go ahead
please referent jurus briefly is it is
it f suggest you want to try to avoid
what happened with the sign structure on
the exit 5 interchange in
nashille yes thank you okay thank you uh
further question yes Ram Newman
please yes thank you just for maybe for
only my clarification this is not an
optional thing you have to have this
done and completed by
2035 um well according to the
mutcd we were supposed to have had it
done by now um but in the in the bill
it's a the completion date is 2035 or
2034 and we could we could meet that
that's 10 years okay follow please
continue repr is there
any stated that you know right now if
you just say you're not going to do it
you don't want to do it nobody wants you
to do it is there any
penalty there potentially could be so
Federal Highway could um could withhold
money um because we we're not
compliant uh so I sort of like you know
we don't have a primary SE seat Bel law
so um we we they withhold I don't know
what it is $5 million a year or
something like that uh because we don't
have a seat belt law so they could do
the same thing with this um eventually
it is it is one section of a thousand
page
document um I'm I think we're at greater
risk when we become the last
state um and the the the pool of states
that haven't done this is shrinking
dramatically
um why this basically started was um in
the Northeast everybody used sequential
the rest of the country used mile post
markers Federal Highway wanted a
standard they basically said majority
rules it's mileage based okay and so
everybody in the Northeast has basically
made the move except for a few holdouts
um including us to to get
changed okay yes please continue further
follow up so the lack of a seat Bel
requirement the penalty the money
withheld for that
couldn't you could pay for this with I
mean if they're withholding 5 million
and this is going to cost 1.3 I mean
could that be could somebody say that oh
I guess they could I just
did okay and and oh really this is the
last one so Vermont is
still Vermont has switch has switched
over so some of their signs I I think
most of their signs on Interstate 89
have a new mile or a previous mile um I
you know we had Delaware the New Jersey
Turnpike so the turnpikes are they're
not federally oversight so um they're
less of risk um and what was the other
state new New York New York and I I I I
believe it's the New York throughway
which is all the way across the state
that's one of their reasons very
expensive thank you okay thank you
represent Newman further question yes
represent Bart please thank you for your
patience um more of a
clarification in the bill it says it
should be completed by
2035 uh you had indicated
that in order to get Federal money to
take care of this usually it's on the
10-year
plan and if it's not in the 10year plan
then we have to use State money more
than likely State money to accomplish
this and it's been my
experience uh or as indicated earlier
also if it's on the 10year plan it keeps
losing its foot place or get lower on
the list so theoretically if it's in the
10-year plan it may never get
accomplished because the federal money
is going to consistently be used on
higher level
priorities would that be correct and so
then we're back facing a a 2035 deadline
using State funds
anyway well I if it was in the 10-year
plan our plan all along because Federal
Highway allowed us was to use um highway
safety uh Improvement plan money it's a
subgroup of the bucket of money we get
and um that could do that much sooner
than 10 years um those those projects
don't go out as far um so we could
probably you know fund that within the
next uh couple years um and start um
doing the projects so it wouldn't have
to wait 10 years to be done okay yes
please continue representative could
this board as an amendment to this uh
set the priority on this to like like
way at the top
versus we we generally don't you know
well we don't set a priority if you
change the date to require it to be done
by you know before 2030 you know like
2030 or something like that that would
be setting the priority more or less um
changing the completion
date thank thank you okay thank you
represent bogar further questions of the
committee from the gentleman from do I I
do have one question too you said
there'll be a transition if this is
implemented drivers will still be able
to underneath the new system which is M
uh mileage based right I mean I'm sorry
I'm get a little confused here they'll
be able to see what the old system is so
they won't get too confused in getting
used to this new system correct there
would there would be both the previous
exit number and the new exit number the
new exit number if this is done and you
said it would you put have these signs
up for a transition for how you don't
now have any idea whether five years 10
years typically when we when we make
changes like this um we would install
the signs and then at the next for the
life of the sign uh which generally
they're about 20 years uh but if the
signs knocked down we wouldn't put it
back up after okay so we would we would
allow for a certain period of time and
then as they essentially die naturally
uh they would would do okay but you're
saying about maximum of a 20 year the
sign so sort of a transition but if it
the sign was knocked down it would be be
sooner it would just go to the the
system the way it is but it would you'd
give drivers hopefully a few years
transition at least so they wouldn't get
too confused I I think the the point
would be is we wouldn't go out and spend
more money to take the signs down okay
we would we would do it as part of the
natural replacement natural or okay all
right thank you gentlemen further
questions representative Abbott please
yes just to follow up on that the figure
that you gave of
$1.4 million would that include having
these the old sign as well as the new
sign when I prepared the uh the fiscal
note that was an assumption that it was
not included um the additional cost it
was the had I had to come up with a
basis for the cost and I took the
absolute minimum which would be
basically an overlay panel over the
existing numbers with the new numbers um
if we were to put temporary uh or um uh
formally formally known as signs up
we'll just call them that um those are
usually placed um smaller less prominent
uh in a location that wouldn't uh we
wouldn't necessarily have a structural
issue we would probably place it on a
post if it were an overhead similar to
what Massachusetts to done um the
additional cost for that is is is not
significant um you know maybe another
$200,000 $300,000 for if we were to add
this additional um you know formally
known as signs
okay okay thank you uh gentleman
representative a fur any further
questions of these two gentlemen the do
from the committee any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for
coming in answering our questions
gentlemen thank you okay is there
anybody else who wishes to testify for
or against House Bill 1547 in the room I
don't see anybody so I will now adjourn
this uh public hearing on House Bill
1547 we are done for the morning and our
next hearing will be at 1:15 when we
take up House Bill
1,43 relative to the capital
appropriation for the legislative
parking garage design that's S one of
the the chairs bills so he should be
here and we will uh hear public to and I
believe something about he there's an
amendment to but I got check with him on
that and we will hear from him on that
bill and we've got two other bills uh
1:45 and 3M and hopefully we'll be done
by by 3:30 4 o'clock at the latest Just
for information okay thank you very much
and enjoy your
lunch enjoy looking at the new legisla
parkes
e
for
okay
two
people he wants to take somewhere in the
neighborh of
400,000 and he wants to replace all of
our chairs throughout the uh throughout
the state
house I guess he's been here 30 years
having trouble repairing and everything
else so here's a perfect source of money
toage so that's what he's then the guy
over at Max Schultz and Max Schulz from
police standards we gave him a capital
appropriation
also
and he we gave him money to replace the
boilers maybe the air conditioning
system in their
building
e
and iuce
[Music]
on represent David
welcome thank you Mr chair uh once again
I'm representative David Mills for the
record I'm here to introduce House Bill
1043 you should have two copies the
original bill and the Amendment I'm here
to introduce HB 1043 as amended with
amendment number
d225 it's to repurpose previously
approved Capital Appropriations for new
needs and uh with that I will turn over
any questions that you have to uh Cher
Terry faf our chief operating officer
for the general court thank you thank
you used to serve I Serv a long it's a
long time ago now Mr chairman you got a
lot of good experience this committee
help it certainly does thank you thank
you very so for the record my name is
Terry PF I'm the chief Operating Officer
for the general court of New Hampshire
and is by way of a little history and uh
I'm here to support 1043 and was request
of the um General Court to repurpose
These funds in uh the session of 2017
for the capital budget of 201819 I
believe it was as when when this
appropriation became uh in the capital
budget it was for design because the gcn
itself our Branch was going to lead the
design at that time we actually went
through the process of our PS and got um
different design companies in place but
then uh By the time all that transpired
Co hit and so that got put on the back
burner and then the new process for the
parking garage took a a different route
so we went through the Public Works
division of U Das and Das took lead on
it the funding got uh got appropriated
in several different pieces of
legislation that you folks uh some of
you folks passed in the previous
sessions and so this money became
available for other purposes so now the
general court part of my job I got
appointed from house chief of staff to
um the Chief Operating Officer and
within the scope of that work is long
range planning plant and property uh
with a whole array of other
responsibilities for the divisions and
all the joint staff so we um uh as part
of that longrange planning we looked at
the needs of the complex and the needs
of the complex are many and Vary some of
them are the seats you're sitting in now
are 50 years old so we're looking at uh
a complete renovation of this building
as we've done on some of you might have
noticed on the first floor of the state
house as well so these dollars would go
towards that and it would be um for the
renovation of the complex when needed
emergency funds for the complex when
needed such as if they're needed for
something that just occurred over the
weekend for instance so there's there's
many things that we need to have
available to keep this operation
operational so the osks can represent
the people that you are sent here to do
so so with this uh these dollars the the
appro even for the chairs if you look at
the chairs that you're sitting in at the
time I think they were $256 a piece back
in
1975 and if you ameiz that we've got a
heck of a good deal on those seats and
they've been well but they're marginal
now they need repairs regularly the
tables if you look underneath our tables
here they're held together and secured
by pieces of plywood because we flip
those over and do that they're they're a
bear to try to move when we reconfigure
the rooms and they serve their purpose
as well as as did the chairs but at 50
years old that's a lifespan as you know
we build things in public works to last
50 to 70 years we're at the end of life
of some of the stuff so that's uh some
of the money will be repurposed for that
as well so it and that's the request as
far as the amendment I believe that no
one from gcn has any problem from that
from the administrator side um uh as far
as that goes I had a discussion with the
speaker the president and the chairman
of the committee so with that I'll
gladly uh field any questions it's nice
nice to be back in front of Public Works
by the way because as as the chairman
mentioned I had a pleasurable time
serving here but it was number of years
ago was in the 90s
so thank you go yes representor Mills
please thank you Mr path I just want to
uh reiterate double check with you to to
establish the fact that this money has
already been appropriated we are not
asking for new funds this is money
that's been appropriated been in the
budgets and it served its purpose and
now we're just re appropriating Sur
plusus funds correct it's not it's not
surplus funds it's a it's funds that are
non-aps for the general core and so we
they're placed in there it's not bonding
money it's it's money that's already
there in our capital budget we just need
to repurpose it so that we can utilize
it for the full complex needs we're
we're bolstering all kinds of things
here we're bolstering your security
levels we're bolstering all uh a number
of needs will be met by these dollars
being available for the complex he thank
you further questions ask representative
fidal
please so does that mean the the money
for
the design of the parking garage is gone
no that means the money for the parking
garage was uh was obtained in a
different piece of legislation and is
already in in process the design and
development of that parking garage is
complete now it's going to planning
board in front of conquer just as a
matter of Statute and the garage that
building will be coming down shortly by
April I have some questions on that if
the parking garage is a different issue
gladly meet with you and discuss that
design of the parking y I'll gladly meet
with you we have a commission that just
barely met uh yesterday uh that's
overseeing the parking garage uh
statutory commission as well so I'll
gladly meet with you I designed to build
100 Commercial IND okay I don't doubt it
repres you you so yeah appreciate you
have doing the follow but if you have
any other questions today that no I just
want when I saw it scratched out here I
just thought it was Dead Issue nope live
issue it's going to be constructed soon
hopefully oh representative Jack please
uh thank you Mr chairman uh would you
agree with me that the funds
appropriated here were laps extended
every time since they were appropriated
so they are still available in that
account that's
correct
yes bogar please just for
clarification this money being moved to
something different would have no
adverse effect on a new legislative
parking garage being built has it will
have absolutely nothing to do with the
parking garage as soon as that title's
changed it doesn't have anything to do
currently because it's already been uh
developed with other dollars that were
put together in legislation this is
money that we have in our general court
capital budget that we need to change
the title so that we can utilize it on
the other needs of the general
court thank you forther questions yes
represent fa me please uh not so much a
question but pointing out that this
amendment deletes the effective date um
clause and does not replace it so I
think that we ought to fix this before
we vote on
it yes Jack please yeah if you read the
uh it say it says amend the bill by
deleting section two and renumbering
section two to read as section two and
three so section two becomes section
three section two becomes
the new text that's here so it does not
delete the effective
date thank you represent Jack uh further
questions please from the committee any
further questions okay thank you again
you you pron I have trouble is it puff
or fad it's puff like cough puff okay
I'll try to remember cough puff puff
I'll try to remember that next I've
answered to many things Mr chairman over
the years and I'll continue to all right
okay good okay thank you very much M
thank you and representative if you'd
like to follow up I'll I'll meet with
you on the garage
okay next I will call upon Mr schz
representing the New Hampshire police
standards and training
ins welcome to public
work you have somebody else who's
accompany you good afternoon and yes uh
director skip was able to make it after
about a four-hour meeting annual meeting
with the police
Chiefs car you don't have but by the end
of your testimony we would appreciate
please for the
record
right
app I just like to thank uh the chair
honorable members of the court for this
time thank you okay thank you sir and I
appreciate you feeling it the okay go
ahead begin please I'm gonna turn this
over to uh to the
major yes thank you for your time this
afternoon uh we approach represent to
mcon with a uh problem that we had with
originally with our boiler replace
replacement project that as you see in
this amendment was originally uh
appropriated in 2019 which was actually
before both the director and myself were
at police standards and training and
those Appropriations have been continued
each by Anum as that boiler project has
gone on that was managed by uh Das
Public Works uh as we reached the end of
this boiler project
we have discovered that the original
scope did not include replacing uh
controller units that are used to
control pumps now I'm not an engineering
expert but uh that control pumps that
control the flow of the water throughout
the building to the thermostats to
control the it properly so effectively
we were unable to uh properly control
the heat in the building we have to
manually each morning run the pumps and
turn them off and make sure that they're
working and it's very manual so when we
approach Public Works to try to get this
corrected uh they got an estimate of
approximately $122,000 to replace to
actually install controllers that will
work with those boilers but they told us
that it was outside the scope of the
original uh appropriation so we had
asked uh representative makoni to please
allow us to be able to uh work on that
controllers there's also a couple other
issues that were discovered with the
heating system and thermostats in the
building that we hope to be able to
repair with the remaining approximately
$400,000 that is left in this
appropriation for that
project along with this uh we struggle
at police standards of training with a
building that is aging and has not had
much uh ongoing repairs since its
original construction and we do have a
problem that bubbled up so to speak this
this winter with our tactical Center
Floor coming up and uh that has been
original to when that cast practical
Center was built I believe in 1994
somewhere in there and uh we don't have
uh funds in our operating budget which
as you know was a zero budget this year
to try to repair that and our initial
estimate to replace it as is is about
$250,000 um so that is another issue we
had asked to hopefully be addressed I
had approached Das and asked for
emergency funding to repair the floor
and then when they looked at the the
scope of emergency funding they said
that the floor would not fit under that
category of uh being able to provide
emergency funding to repair it so that's
why we asked for that to be included in
here the third issue we have that we've
added here is we have two projects one
of which is very very important to the
essential operations of police standards
and training that were uh capital
projects originally that in 2020 became
arpa funed projects
uh and with the several years that have
gone by Public Works has finally got an
engineer to evaluate the cost of those
projects and they far exceed what we
have allocated through gopher funds so
we have been asking uh the goer office
to find additional funding specifically
for the most important project is which
is our range ventilation uh repair uh
the firing range which is essential to
the operation of the police academy as
you can imagine uh that ventilation
system is original and it is not working
properly and so we don't want to have
that combustion or that atmosphere
That's not healthy building up inside
the building and so we've been trying to
get that uh ventilation system replaced
and so we've also added in here that
depending on whether or not we get the
go for money uh we're hoping to be as
flexible as possible with the little bit
of funds we have to fix the Tactical
Center floor the boiler and and
hopefully get that range project done by
combining those those arpa funds I hope
that makes sense um it's it's a
complicated kind of a pro problem we
have that we're trying every which way
to solve uh to to sustain the use of the
building as best we can thank
you thank you Mr chair uh and thank you
for taking the question uh so this
figure uh is all inclusive and it will
cover all the items that you have just
discussed it will replace the uh the
facility improvements for the boilers on
for the for speaking to each other the
uh the your range ventilation problems
that you're having and the floors this
will cover all all those items no it
will not oh it will not
no this was meant to in case we don't
get the go for money we have some
flexibility to use this $400,000 so
you've got the flexibility to use it as
necessary in this correct if we were say
okay yes thank you okay
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question what is your
anticipated amount you're hoping to get
from
goer the uh both of the projects that
were approved with goer funds uh were uh
initially appropriated and once uh the
state Engineers came in with the the
final assessment uh both of the projects
were appropriated at less than 50% of
the cost of each one of the projects as
initially uh outlined the exact number
uh with uh that reflects the total
shortfall of the two arpa projects is uh
1 milli
576,000
for this I'm looking here under Section
A of the amendment I'm assuming we're
talking about the amendment uh that'll
be 1043 Amendment um it says under
Section A a mil
35,000
1,35 and then for purchase training
certificate database
$150,000
um
so you're looking to appropriate
$1,185
th000 negative sir so that that funding
was spent on the boilers the remaining
funds that are in that account come to
about $400,000 and that is what we're
asking to be able to it's
$440,000 and $
34.7 440,000 K that's 440 340
so followup
please so you've got already the 440,000
now you're looking to appropriate more
money we I think our effort was to just
uh receive the permission of this court
to use that
$400,000 in a more flexible way and we
wanted to be transparent to come here to
get that permission for that uh the
ability to kind of use those funds that
have already been appropriated for the
boiler project to just have flexibility
to work across all these projects if if
we have an opportunity to get access to
more funds we are certainly we certainly
stand ready to to work in that direction
as
well follow up please Contin so the
440,000 you want to that's left over
from replacing your bowler you're going
to use that to change the
controllers and you're going to put a
floor
in
and that's pretty much
it if we had any uh
excess uh we would like to be able to
just expend that money that's already
sitting in our account on these other in
support of completion of those other
projects as well we have no idea what if
any funds we're going to get from the
Gopher office to support the two capital
projects that are uh have been
underapproximation funds have nothing to
do with the garage funds for the uh
legislative parking garage no nothing
whatsoever thank you I sense some maybe
some confusion by representative Bogart
and I'm wondering I don't know if you
gentlemen would mind we have Christopher
Shay from the legislative budget
assistance he might be able to help
clarify if you gentlemen don't mind and
at the end Mr Shay if you could fill out
a pink card though but I appreciate you
coming in
good morning for uh good afternoon for
the record Chris Shay from the
legislative budget Assistance Office uh
just to clarify for the committee House
Bill 1043 is not a new appropriation nor
is the amendment that's before you as
well both of those projects are
repurposing prior approved Capital
Appropriations from prior Capital
budgets so these are situations where
there was money left and the agencies or
the branch in the case of the bill is
introduced want to use those funds for
other purposes so it's already been
appropriated it's already been bonded um
now they just want to expand the use and
specifically here with the police
standards and Council
um they have gotten some money through
arpa which they've testified to you that
it wasn't quite enough to complete the
project they have a boiler project that
they completed which originally was
appropriated a milion
$35,000 and they have $400,000
remaining that they would like to use
for several different projects but
they're still in the process of working
with the governor's office and gopher to
um obtain potentially additional arpa
funds once they know that they would
have a better idea as to where the money
would be applied but again it's it's no
new appropriation you're not um
expanding the bonding Authority this
money has already been appropriated
through a capital budget and all the
bill does is change the purpose by
expanding the title so hopefully that
helps a little bit um but I figured I'd
come over and try to help you with that
if it was going to be useful thank you
Mr Shay questions of Mr Shay from the
committee yes go ahead please representa
Newton thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my question so these projects
that are you're trying to get the money
to spend on are they approved by gopher
so the goer money if this goes forward
the goer money can be used towards these
projects that's already been cleared so
there's two projects that the um Council
has gotten money from arpa that's been
it's gone through gopher gone through
governor and Council and they're allowed
to use that um as was testified by the
director when the projects came back
from Public Works the amounts
appropriated were less than 50% of the
actual cost of the projects so now
they're trying to the the uh council is
now trying to find um sources of revenue
that they can use to complete the
projects that they have this is One
Source by the amending the capital
budget because the
$400,000 if you don't approve this today
what will happen is at the end of the
banum it will lapse and um if you were
remember during the capital budget
process you go through potential laps
Appropriations and see if you can reuse
those or repurpose those so this is a
kind of a in a sense a jump on that
you're repurposing These funds to allow
for several other projects that weren't
in the original capital project capital
budget excuse me
does that answer your quest question rep
of
Newton further yeah it does answer my
question but now I've got a concern why
did you wait till today and tell us we
have to do it today is that what I just
heard you say no I'm not saying you have
to do anything today I'm just trying to
explain to you that's what I thought I
heard I thought I heard you said we have
to act on this
today but that may there may have been
some conversation before I got here no
no was you just said it you just said I
said if you act today on this
yes that's not not that you have to it's
up to this committee to decide whether
they want to approve the bill and or the
amendment thank you all I'm doing is
trying to give you information so you
can make a a thoughtful decision an
informed
decision yes thank you okay Mr Shay
further questions of Mr Shay please for
members of the
committee okay I think we're all set for
now but I appreciate you and I
appreciate you filling in a pin card too
okay further questions but going back to
the two gentlemen uh Mr Schult and Mr
shipper or skipp skip okay I'll try to
remember Mr Skipper further questions of
these two gentlemen from New Hampshire
police standards and training yes
representative AB please yes the other
thing I just wanted
to
Def make sure that I heard it right is
the projects that you were thinking
about doing but one of them I think that
was skipped in there is the ventilation
and the the firing
range that's part of it as well uh that
is correct
sir thank you representative Abbott
further questions of these two gentlemen
from members of the committee uh the
only thing I have a question if let's
say you're talking about getting money
from uh gopher and other sources if
let's say you everything goes your way
and you get the money to take care of
these projects do you anticipate from
what if let's say we pass this bill as
amended having any additional money left
over I know I realize sometimes projects
the bids come in higher Etc do you anti
or do you want to you intend to topend
it all if we appropriate this bill the
way it's
amended if we were to receive goer
funding for our for our arpa projects
that we had including the range up to
the amount that it's is needed we would
not spend all of these funds they would
they would lapse back into the capital
fund uh we only if that happens like you
said I only want to use this for the
money to fix the current boiler problem
which is the controllers and a leaky eru
unit and and that's that's thermostats
that's it and and we would also end the
floor and the floor sorry which is a
safety issue so whatever's left from
that so if let's say you got your all
your money from other sources and didn't
need to spend all this it just would be
return it would be a lapse basically in
the next capital budget is that what
you're saying probably we'd have to deal
with it then as far I mean I'm just I
don't know how how things will go but
yes although we did get an estimate that
the Tactical Center floor is going to
cost $250,000 okay which was quite a
shock all right thank you gentlemen
F please would it be safe to say that
you guys are trying to be a little
frugal
and hoping to get the money for the
project not counting on what goer may
tell you because they that money is
constantly revolving because everybody's
trying to get it so you may say they may
say well you're going to get 400,000 you
may get 200,000 is that kind of a
concern you've got and that's why you're
asking for this amount 100%
100% represent new further questions
from the committee of these two
gentleman rep jurus okay go ahead please
thank you CH are you at this point is is
it is your training center and your your
um uh staff ready to put this this money
to work by uh by by beginning on The
Replacements is the engineering and
planning done for for these for this eff
for for the controllers we are all set
to go to for the boiler controllers
absolutely and we have two estimates for
the flooring so uh and as far as the the
arpa projects they've been engineered
and quoted and are ready to
go so just briefly the sooner the better
for you for this 400,000 plus
amount okay yeah thank you and the other
concern would be uh we cannot um we will
need to continue with our uh normal
operations we have to continue to train
police officers at the same time and so
uh as quick as these might happen uh we
also have plans in play to be able to
work around our normal operations while
these different projects are being
completed thank you further questions
from the
committee all right I see no more
questions so thank you very much for
coming in
and thank you for your time thank you
for your
time
thank you and good afternoon and it's so
good to see all of you um I don't think
this is a committee that I've spoken to
in the recent
past um
so I come to you today with a
bill
um hb1
1488 you guys all set okay um so I'm
introducing this bill hb1
1488 to today relative to Hazard
mitigation
funding with this bill I'm asking to
place money in the existing Disaster
Relief Fund which is found in RSA Pon
46a in order to assist towns with
limited resources to help them pay for
implementation of their Hazard
mitigation plans small towns especially
often do not have the tax base to afford
the huge costs of Hazard mitigation
plans many can barely pay for their
regular Road and equipment maintenance
and they also cannot afford to wait
years to save up money to implement
costly Hazard mitigation
plans given that New Hampshire has been
severely impacted by several storms over
the past few years resulting in the
Declaration of disaster throughout the
state and given that New Hampshire has
an interest
in helping municipalities prevent or
reduce the loss of life and damage to
property and infrastructure in future
natural disasters it would seem that the
strengthening of Municipal
infrastructure is important for the
safety Commerce and enjoyment of all New
Hampshire
citizens I believe it is in the interest
of citizens of the state to provide a
means to assist
municipalities to implement Hazard
mitigation projects and plans to prevent
future damage from weather related
events and natural disaster
Masters the N National Institute of
building Sciences did a study that
showed enormous benefits in investing in
Hazard mitigation plans I sent a copy of
the report to the members of this
committee
mitigation protects lives improves
safety prevents property loss and
decreases disruption of daily
life research shows a return of $6 for
every dollar invested in mitigation
activities that help reduce risk and
future disaster losses and furthermore
according to
ncsl policy makers should consider
creating Statewide resilience plans that
centralize their approach to dealing
with the challenges associated with
disasters the reports indicate that
expenditures for the Federal Emergency
Management agency's public assistance
program which municipalities seek
reimbursement from after a natural
disaster alone increased by 23% When
comparing the 2000 to 2009 and 2010 to
2019 decades the federal government as a
whole spent at least $460 billion on
disaster costs from 2005 to
2019 and we are already hearing that
FEMA is beginning to run out of
reimbursement money and that they're
backing away from funding reimbursement
requests it's been all in the news in
the past uh year or two and as a state
we have to be prepared to help
ourselves this bill adds money to an
existing fund for purposes of Hazard
mitigation grant funding and sets up
criteria for application for the funding
by a
municipality the municipality would have
to have a municipal Hazard mitigation
plan in place to begin with this
proposal that I'm offering would just
help them get started on implementation
which might otherwise be put on the
Shelf due to lack of
resources these small towns in New
Hampshire need our help they simply
don't have the tax base to do these
expensive projects in a timely manner
and that exposes them to incredible
damage due to weather related in
incidents so I thank you and I would be
happy to answer any questions you have
regarding this um proposed
legislation question from
of thank you Mr chairman and
representative Aon thank you very much
for your testimony I appreciate it um
and in the interested time Mr chairman I
do have four questions so I'll I'll
defer to you as to whether I can
continue or not so okay I think it's
okay if they're not you know four
questions probably I'll ask somebody
else I appreciate I appreciate the
latitude thank you Mr chairman thank you
for letting me know um representative
Aaron do you know who administered is
the disaster relief fund I believe it is
um in the department of
safety and uh I believe it is the uh New
Hampshire
um Homeland Security emergency
management so I think that would be
director
buckon follow up Mr chairman thank you
how did you arrive at the $2 million
appropriation in the bill well it just
seems uh to me just based on uh what
I've seen in terms of damage in my own
town in aworth that um $2 million would
have really helped us a lot uh to to to
help
um you know get things put in place and
uh you know some mitigation plans are
more expensive than others we all know
uh as members of our own uh Town select
boards or just involved in our town
government that the costs of culverts
and and ditching and uh even Road
diversion you know building a road
that's different from where it is any of
these um Hazard mitigation plans can be
quite pricey um there's also the issue
of you know what our contractor fees
have gone up quite a bit costs are
expensive for these kinds of projects
and um these towns you know they try
very hard they try and squirrel away
money to do it but then you know you
need a new dump truck or you need a new
fire TR or you need something
that's a more pressing issue than um you
know some some of the plans that the
town in good faith puts in place I
follow up again Mr chairman please
continue thank you on line line 31 of
page two of the
bill it reads a current copy of the
municipal Hazard mitigation plan period
is there a legal definition a legal
definition to this specific
term I'm not sure um okay as far as I
understand the hazard mitigation plan
that a town comes up with is a document
uh and and most times they work with um
Homeland Security emergency management
in New Hampshire to draft it that's what
I understand no I okay I appreciate what
you're saying then lastly on page two
line
33 where it says the last two words a
declared disaster is this a federal de
declaration or a state declaration
well right now we don't have a state
declaration I do have another bill and
another committee that is seeking to
have a state declaration uh that would
be made by our uh Commissioner of safety
in the department of safety but right
now uh Declaration of disaster would be
a presidential declaration thank you I
appreciate that thank you Mr chairman
okay thank you
repres further questions of represent
Aon for members of the committee uh yes
representative a please yes I just
wondered if there was any specific
criteria U for
qualifying
um for this
relief well I had set some uh in in
section
four of
uh from line on page one line
28 to uh page two down to line 10 that
would have some of the criteria for
applying for this kind of Grant from the
state so so that you would have to
provide a current Co the municipality
would have to provide a current copy of
their Municipal haard mitigation plan a
description of the specific project Road
or Bridge Project to be implemented and
the manner in which the hazard
mitigation being implemented improves
the infrastructure and prevents damage
from future natural disasters um item C
the amount of money being requested for
the hazard mitigation project and
demonstration of financial need of the
municipality for implementing this
project an explanation and reasons why
the municipality is unable to fund the
project implementation in a timely
manner on its
own and any supporting documentation to
demonstrate that the infrastructure to
be improved and protected is of
significant or critical importance to
Commerce the citizen safety or provides
access through into or out of the
municipality and the reasons why I put
that there is because you know um it's
one thing to to do some Hazard
mitigation on some side dirt road but I
think it's more important for these
projects to be done for the more heavily
traveled roads where Commerce is
happening in and out of a town and
municipality maybe you've got um a maple
sugar farm a dairy farm a blueberry pick
your own blueberry whatever those roads
that are more typically used for
Commerce or for Traverse through and in
and out of the municipality of course
we'd want to protect those and those are
become more of a priority than the other
kinds of roads in town thank you thank
you sure than you f
question thank you m thank you Mr chair
and thanks for answering my
question section three um mentions a
once in the calendar year a grant being
available for up to 50,000 is that
really going to do much for some of the
problems that people you're talking
about big problems excuse me yeah sure
um let's see you said section three
which page was that on oh yes yes page
one I'm sorry um well I thought that you
know that might be um a good start for a
municipality maybe they don't maybe that
$50,000 is something that's preventing
them from getting started I mean I don't
think it's up to the state to fund an
entire project but I think if the if the
state can offer some portion of that
funding it would really go a long way
especially in these smaller towns uh to
help get a project going and get it off
the ground as opposed to
being you know so so expensive that um
the town can't afford it so I it was
just a number that I thought was
reasonable um and again the intent of
this bill is not necessarily to fund an
an entire mitigation plan but at least
to help the municipality get started in
um in implementing
it thank
you thank you again Mr chairman I
appreciate and I thank the general lady
for for taking my questions I appreciate
it page three of the bill um section
three where you have a uh a committee
going be comprised of a nonprofit
Community Human Service organizations
disastrous Disaster Response cap
Municipal
organization and I noticed that
Municipal organization was highlighted
in italicize so is this existing
language and that we're adding Municipal
because I really felt it should be
better to find the whole thing yeah that
if we're going to if if the bill is
going to have some type of a Disaster
Relief Committee that it be more
specifically targeted as opposed to
having a generic generic titles To Who
It compris of this particular committee
so thank you for that question that's a
very good question yes it is amending
existing statute okay um the existing
statute I guess was meant um primarily
to assist
individuals although I don't know that
any individuals have ever ever made use
of this
statute um so what I when I saw this uh
that a fund has already been developed
which by the
way um right now as I understand only
contains about
$45,000 um what I thought was to amend
this language that's existing in statute
to include municipalities so that
municipalities can have a a statutory
vehicle to obtain said
funding Fallout Mr chairman thank you
and then on section
four the maintenance of the records of
dispersements uh Disaster Relief
Committee line 11 every six months
following the effective date of the the
section I guess my question to you is
are you comfortable with six months
because I felt that maybe depending on
the nature of of
the municipality applying for disaster
relief may require a higher frequency of
of review well this was uh again in
current statute and I believe the the
Department of Homeland Security
emergency management um is required to
make this report every six months I
didn't know that it was would be
necessary to make it any um you know
sooner sooner sooner frequency I mean if
if the committee feels that um
any set any other language in the
existing statute needs to be amended or
should be amended for clarity or for
purposes of expediency I'd be more than
happy to put in an amendment or work
with you to do that or however you want
to do it it's it would be your bill
right now any yep I ruin that term
earlier this
morning okay but I I'm I'm more than
open to have you make any kinds of
changes to existing statute as I tried
to no I appreciate it thank you for your
time thank you Mr chairman void further
questions of Representative Aaron from
members of the committee are there any
other questions want to be sure oh yes
just one more comment thank you for the
report oh sure I appreciate the
hyperlink thank you yeah no the the
reports are are very useful I know um
one of them is very lengthy and goes
into uh quite a lot of detail in
specific hazard mitigation 659 Pages
exactly but there are uh there are part
of that report I think that that makes
some very Salient points
about when we do Hazard mitigation we
are saving ourselves a lot of money we
are we are pre helping to prevent future
loss of life of resources property um
all of those things and as we see with
more the frequency of these kinds of
flooding events that we've had we had a
flood in July 2021 another in in
2023 and it's not
because um it's not necessarily
because uh the damage that's being done
is not necessarily because of the
flooding in particular but it's because
we haven't really kept up with a lot of
our infrastructure to harden it to more
severe kinds of weather we also have an
issue with I
feel with the way in which we do or
don't do are stream management you have
a lot of streams that are backed up and
blocked up with debris that have not
been cleared over the years and maybe
that's a fault of our own Department of
Environmental Services who believes that
um when a stream is blocked up and it
gets diverted around and then threatens
buildings or whatever yes you can fix
that but they're but they belief is that
these streams go through a Natural
Evolution and we shouldn't disturb the
stream beds and we shouldn't disturb the
habitats of animals that set up life
there but by the same token I mean we've
got property that's involved and lives
that are involved and roadways that are
involved and I think that um to say that
we should leave things alone after a
flood and let things happen is not
really a good policy I mean we we really
ought to be when when these streams run
their Banks and they bring down a lot of
rock and vegetation and silt those
things should be cleared out so that the
stream can function
properly as it was before um so I I find
that there's an aspect of stream
management there's an aspect of also um
doing our due diligence in maintaining
our roadways our
bridges and um and making sure that
flooding doesn't happen where where
we've seen it so I think
um the hazard mitigation for for at
least any of the flooding that we've
been seeing experiencing in many of our
towns um is a great investment and I
think the state needs to help these
towns um bring these projects to
fruition and um I I hope that you would
consider that I think uh a grant
um system would go a long way to help
our
towns and um especially the towns that
are in need I mean aworth and I don't
want to keep talking about aworth but
that's you know the town I live in and
um we have an operating budget of $1.3
million it's not a big town we've got
850 voters or 850 people that live in
town um so our tax base is limited and
we can only afford to do so much
and when the other thing I want to point
out too is that when these flooding
events happen an a town works with FEMA
first of all you know that's a takes a
long time we're still it's three years
from the 2021 flood we're still waiting
for reimbursement money from FEMA so I
mean the money is not forthcoming it's a
bureaucratic mess it's it's horrific for
our towns who are uh Limited in the
amount of people they have in
administration to work and do their own
work but also do all the reporting
necessary you might not have a very
large road crew but my point is that
um FEMA when when they reimburse your
money you are working on a project to
put the road back to where it was before
the flooding event that doesn't include
mitigation so why would you fix
something to be the the same way that it
was before and have yourself put at risk
to have the same flooding incident the
same damage be done again and then if
you look at one of our roads in aworth
cranebrook Road um that was taken out
totally the entire two three miles of it
was totally destroyed in
2021 and because there was no mitigation
money we put the road back to the way it
was before
and guess what when 2023 came around and
we had that flooding in July the entire
Road was washed out again totally
destroyed and so all that money and time
well and we we didn't even finish we
only got temporary work done um all that
time and money was wasted because we
didn't really put in the kind of Road
plan that would have fixed the kinds of
problems that we were having to begin
with and so it's a problem and um and I
and I think um some grant money being
made available to municipalities will go
a long way to fix these kinds of
problems thank
you uh further question repr Aon from
the committee uh before I did everybody
get the information email to
us now okay and and this information you
gave you some hard
only a few copies but I have a link to
that in the email that I sent okay
that's that same information yes sir I
do have
hard we have a hard y okay so again any
other
questions okay and and again I would be
most welcome to working with any of you
to put in any kind of amendments to um
fix current statute language that is
maybe inadequate at this time or or
clarify anything I'd be happy to do that
okay thank
you any of you want to
work okay thank you so much okay thank
you what a great
committee are there is there anybody
else here in for or
against
and
if I uh if I could pull you for a moment
they this Friday I'm looking for a a
member Public Works to fill in for a
vacancy on long range Capital planning
it's a it comes at a nice hour 9ine
o'clock in the morning on Friday and our
work will be done there's only two
things to hear and we'll be done uh
within a half hour 45 minutes and I'm
wondering if you should have there
should be an email going out to you uh
we're shy one person for a quorum and if
I could have someone that would like to
come in Friday morning at nine o'clock
uh then we could hear I think we have
two cases uh commissioner Stewart has
needs something
done you
there all right so the rest of you
stopped thinking about
it let me ask you this though last time
we went
this
e
South conquered that's
right all right okay I'm sorry okay
thank you representative Jack so
everybody hear me so I we've just talked
with the chair and I think we've talked
with the prime sponsor and probably
because it was a mistake that the chair
myself and I don't know you can blame
other people to I want to get blame
because we all make mistakes that this
should have gone to Science Tech and
energy so what we want to do is recess
this hearing and hopefully the clerk and
the speaker whatever can figure it out
and either they'll reassign it to
Science Tech and or they'll change the
heading and will come back to our for
another public he hearing and give the
bill its due uh wherever it goes because
uh we just have a problem that we
screwed up and to be fair to the
sponsors we don't we want to at least
have a public hearing of the bill so
what we're going to I'm going to do is
I'm going to recess the public hearing
on this bill
1510 and let the clerk and the speaker
figure it out and and it may come back
but we it probably they'll have to
change the heading or otherwise it
probably will go to Science Tech and
energy and I want to on behalf of the
committee apologize to the prime sponsor
sorry for the mixup uh thank you very
much for taking care of this error and I
just wanted to encourage everybody on
this committee to at least read the
article that I handed out understanding
that I may not actually be able to
present to you in the future I may be
going elsewhere but big exciting and
interesting things are happening with
Eves and our grid in New Hampshire um
and I think that this is a great
opportunity for a commission which is
why I brought forth the bill so uh
please take that under consideration I
hope I'm back to present to you but if
I'm not thank you for your time okay and
I think it's important because this may
come back or come on the floor so I
think it's important we all at least
understand the one side of the issue and
then hopefully make an intelligent
decision again thank you very
much 151 and again thank you very much
point of order I thought you we were
going into recess oh recess you can't
you
can't you can't close the hearing you
have to go to I apologize repres I'm
recessing will be
okay so that concludes today's
activities uh again I ask you to leave
your name plates on your desk because
I've got to work with the administrative
assistant the chair to make sure we know
who's sitting where so when we come back
the name plates are in the proper place
I know some members of the committee are
not here but hopefully everybody's
satisfied with where they're
sitting um if not let myself know or the
chair but and those who didn't come
today are going to have to be satisfied
with the choices they have left and
again thank you very much everybody
appreciate your patience again sorry for
the screw up
okay